check this out exclusive fox news video
showing dramatic scenes from our
southern border
migrants some with young children
looking exhausted
and struggling to get across the rio
grande river in texas
president biden has insisted that the
border is closed and that the situation
is under control
but this stunning video tells a much
different story our own bill millusion
on the ground and reporting over 50
migrants mostly from venezuela
crossed in that one spot just this
morning local authorities say border
patrol is so overwhelmed that they've
been forced to deal with the influx of
migrants
it's tying up our resources it's
frustrating because there's no
no answers that are being given there's
not a
there's not i don't believe that there's
a plan in place right now you know we
need more manpower we need people in dc
to make a decision do it do their job
jesse it was wild watching that live
this morning just like unfold
right in front of your eyes yeah the
border patrol looks like
guest greeters out there helping people
across
is joe biden a member of the sinaloa
cartel
that's what he's doing he's honestly
helping them traffic
these kids into our country you're
sitting there on the border
kid comes in under 18. biden helps
smuggle the
illegal immigrant through if you're an
adult that comes with a minor
can't separate families so they give you
a bus ticket an 1100 cash
or even a plane ticket and now you're
into the country
i've never seen anything like this
anytime an american sees this they
obviously feel compassion for these
people
but i feel compassion for the american
people and right now
biden's in the business with the cartels
he's literally the middle man
when it comes to a human smuggling
pipeline maybe
i guess the only pipeline joe biden
supports if you bring them in
cartel brings them up through mexico
hands them to the border patrol
and then the border patrol just hands
him to hhs
sends him to a hotel or sends him to a
convention center
and then eventually you know they send
him to a sponsor
guess who controls the sponsor the
cartel
so the cartels are on both sides and
joe's in the middle man
taxpayers are being used to human
smuggle that's what's happening here and
the new democrat
talking point is oh we're speeding this
up really
so now the speed of human smuggling
that's now something we should be proud
of we're getting these illegal
immigrants out of the federal
government's hand faster
to who to the cartels on the other side
of the border and they're working off
cartel debt
how do you think cartel get debt gets
worked off you think through legal
activities
that's how the crime comes in and we
know it costs a fortune
biden already put a couple billion on
the books just for this
the video speaks for itself there's no
way to defend it
and and biden is complicit and katie as
jesse said about three billion dollars
spent since february so far
um and i believe i don't know were you
just recently on the border or
you've had you've had some connect some
contacts down there
telling you what's going on yep yeah i
was um
in pinal county about a month ago which
starts 70 miles north of the border but
because the reservation there
doesn't allow uh border patrol really or
for a fence to be put in a wall to be
put in the border really starts 70 miles
into arizona 45 minutes south from
phoenix and
yes you're seeing what's happening on
your screen now you're seeing this
happening in arizona but the difference
is what you're seeing here
is people turning themselves in i go to
the place of the thousands of people who
are being smuggled
in places like pinal county up to
phoenix who are not
turning themselves in who want to evade
getting detected the people who are
involved in criminal enterprises and the
bottom line is that
human beings are now a more expensive
commodity
than drugs are the cartels are making
more money
smuggling people which is easier to do
than smuggling drugs
then they are making money on narcotics
while they're still doing
those things as well but they're making
money on this and in these videos if
you're if you know what you're looking
for
the guy with his head wrapped in all
black
he's shuffling them across the river
that guy's a cartel member he's a
smuggler that guy right there the guy
who grabs the kid before it drowns in
the river
he's not part of a family unit and you
also see these guys with the boats who
are smuggling these people across the
boats
well where's mexico on this they know
these guys are operating on that side
of the river where are some where the
mexican authorities saying no
you can't do the smuggling operations
here there's zero enforcement
on the other side of the border where
are the mexican authorities on that and
the national security implication here
and what they told me dana is
it's not just venezuelans there are
people from yemen there are people from
african countries there are people from
countries that have completely collapsed
that have terrorist groups running the
country
and the cartels don't care where these
people are from in fact they charge more
money
for people who are from countries that
are on lists in the united states
as higher risk for national security
incidents and so
the people who are getting away are also
the story that's going on told here
one the um there's a new ap poll that
shows that
biden's approval rate is quite good
overall but on immigration he's under
water 43
approved 54 percent disapprove um they
at the white house are trying to
maintain that everything's getting
better
does it look like it yeah i mean things
are getting better you know this video
i think is such a distortion because
every administration i just want to say
every administration people are crossing
the rio grande
illegally this is like a daily activity
throughout you know the last hundred
years i don't know that there's anything
new here except that there was a video
there today and it fits in with all the
people who want to beat up on biden
about
immigration so yes we've had a problem
at the border
but yes dana to reiterate the point that
you said
is coming from the biden administration
things are getting better
we're seeing huge improvements on three
fronts we're seeing the number of
unaccompanied miners down 88 percent
in the last month so that's nearly 90
percent decrease
in the number of unoccupied from an
all-time highest month yeah
secondly we're seeing a decline in the
number of children being held in border
patrol custody those who are being held
also
are being processed out more quickly and
third the overall
border arrest for illegal crossings
right now is leveling off
a sign that fewer people are crossing so
the surge we've been seeing in this
cycle
seems to be going down it's still the
case we have a problem and i wish
congress would finally stop with the
selfies or
create these videos to create hysteria
and do something
well the video wasn't created for
hysteria but just we were on the border
and this just happened to be there greg
and that's how it was
there every day and the number you could
take the picture any day
greg but never have decreased from
border patrol but now these children are
being held by hhs
the saddest thing about that argument is
that we've heard this argument
every single day it happens every day
it happens every day sure a few kids
drown
some get raped right but it happens
every day it's been going on for 100
years
it was odd that when it was happening
under trump though it mattered right
it was the immoral work of a racist man
supported by racist
supporters but now when there's a
democrat it's like
this stuff happens all the time relax
everybody you will actually see this
type of argument
in every case by the media when a
democrat is in power suddenly
you start becoming more complex or
nuanced about the issue
when before you were you would come out
right and say this is damn wrong if i
were gonna write a book right now
and i'm thinking about it i would call
it incentives for dummies
because every single issue that we are
facing right now has to do with a
failure to understand incentives
number one you pay people to do nothing
you're gonna have high unemployment
people aren't gonna work two you defund
police or you talk about the funding
police that rhetoric
leads to rising crime we've seen that
you don't have any school choice what
does that lead to
bad schools you stop building pipelines
oil prices rise you ban drugs you create
a street market for it and in this case
this is an incentive palooza you're
waving people into this country
while loudly proclaiming that the guy
that was before you was a big mean
racist
as you stop his wall and you think about
what the wall is
that the wall would have worked because
it was a physical it was physical
evidence of a disincentive all you got
to do was look at the wall
and you realize they don't want people
coming here illegally
and it's it's it's part messaging and
it's part product it actually works
i think it's strange that the people
that claim to want something done
were the first people that were against
the wall which tells you they don't want
it to be done
they want the outer collapse of this so
they could remake it in whatever shape
they want hopefully
for them to create a larger voting block
that's a cynical way of looking at it
one book at a time greg
yes take your time yes and you have one
coming out so i do not want to compete
with your books
just because yes please thank you can i
say something real quick
next year about the wall issue do you
remember when nancy pelosi fought donald
trump on five billion dollars for the
wall
well we've already spent three billion
dollars on this crisis in the first few
months of the year so
puts the number in perspective hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else